[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
it's part of the intro
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty we will not
tolerate intolerance from lauren bobert
marjorie taylor green steve bannon
donald trump ron desantis any fascist
out there
who wants to tear down our democracy we
do not have to tolerate them
full stop do not have to tolerate any of
their fascism whatsoever ron desantis
goes to pa
to um stump for
mastriano or
the moose the mussolini the mussolini of
pa
ron desantis is trying to really make
himself the the king hitler of america
manga king trying to take over it looks
like him and donald trump are in a
little scuffle
of who is the king who is the dictator
who's the leader of the moglodites
as lauren bobert gets on twitter and
says oh
you ta you tolerant left are intolerant
of trump supporters yep that's that's
correct
that is right we are intolerant of your
intolerance and we are not going to put
up with it
it's just not a thing that we should
have to do in this country this is a
democracy
this is a liberal democracy
we have freedom we have liberty here and
we do not have to tolerate your
intolerance it is not a thing that we
have to put up with
we've done it for long enough for the
past five or six years or so it's enough
it's enough for the [ __ ] stupid
it's enough of it this morning there's a
video of
steve bannon
marjorie taylor green
mike lindell
on the same screen at the same stage
speaking into microphones
talk about a talk about stupid holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and steve bannon
says
out loud into a microphone that when the
republicans when the nazi party of
america first takes the house back
we're going to make marjorie taylor
green the speaker of the house
did you need any other did you need
another reason like another reason
let's just say you weren't quite there
yet
on making sure to engage in your
democracy
and i'm not just talking about voting i
tweeted this that if you need another
reason or you're still looking for one
here's a [ __ ] reason for you
their plan is to make marjorie taylor
green the speaker of the house
that's that's their plan a steve
bannon's plan
mike lindell seemed to like it too
i mean you know
he likes anything that puts fascist in
control of stuff
the pelo nazi you know the my pillow
nazi
but marjorie taylor greene their plan is
to make her the speaker of the house
think about this for a second
she's gonna win a race
in georgia there is very slim chance and
i want marcus to win sure
but there is a very slim chance that
that district in georgia that's why she
moved there
folks she moved
to that district
to win it
because she knows the makeup
and i'm sure marcus will run a great
campaign and really give her a shot and
give her a run for her money but
she's probably gonna win that race
so what are you gonna do are you gonna
sit at home and go up democrats got this
slam dunk no problem
and risk
risk
that steve bannon
will threaten violence against members
of the house republican members of the
house
to make sure
that they put marjorie taylor green in
charge of our house our house of
representatives you don't think steve
bannon will call for
for action
if they don't make her the speaker
you don't think
he's been calling he's been calling on
all the moglodites to save trump
from this search and seizure of
classified documents that he stole
they're continuing this nonsense over
the weekend
chad wolf of all people
the former acting
secretary of the department of homeland
security comes up and
he decides he's going to make his
thoughts known as if anyone gives a
frat's ass what that fascist chad wolf
says
but steve bannon of course of course if
they win the house they will use threats
against our country
to direct them at republicans to do
their bidding they continue to do it
they continue to do it dan crenshaw same
[ __ ] thing
he tries to rebuke the republican party
they call him a globalist they call him
woke
and he spreads more lies on tv why the
media lets these [ __ ] on tv i
have no idea no clue
no clue why they continue this nonsense
that you would allow someone like dan
crenshaw who thinks it's cool to wear an
eye patch
who talks about who talks about how
republicans are doing performative
politics the guy who jumped out of an
airplane and wears an eye patch on a
regular basis yeah okay dan cringer get
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
we have more liz cheney news she's
speaking out again
of course
but these republicans are boxed in folks
and we got them right where we want them
but we have to engage in our democracy
and there's no better excuse
no better excuse than steve bannon's
great idea is to have marjorie taylor
green as the speaker of the house
just just the thought just the thought
of that
absolutely makes you want to [ __ ]
puke
but they're in springfield missouri have
been all weekend they're they're gonna
unveil some great evidence that's
supposed to
turn our democracy and not into nazi
germany overnight or some [ __ ] i know
they have like two people attending that
place half the [ __ ] chairs were empty
in that son of a [ __ ] it was worse than
the last event that mike lindell had
that was supposed to
make donald trump king or whatever the
[ __ ] they're trying to do
batshit crazy folks
batshit crazy stuff but
steve bannon marjorie taylor green and
mike lindell are sitting there
conspiring
out loud in front of a microphone
calling to action
that marjorie taylor green will be the
speaker of the house if they win back
the house chamber the republicans what
[ __ ] more evidence what more reason
do you need then to go
[ __ ] vote and just doubt me on the
fact that steve bannon
will make sure
to get his little internet soldier
troops is
his keyboard cowboys to go out there
his oath keepers and his proud boys his
domestic terrorists
his band of maglites
to threaten republicans and doing it
doubt me
doubt me
just sit at home don't engage in your
democracy
don't make sure to talk to people about
what is important what is the issue as
of now and the issue as of now is to be
intolerant of intolerance it's enough of
this nonsense
it's enough of this ron desantis donald
trump marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert trump isn't [ __ ] this this
america first nazi party
it's enough of the [ __ ] enough of the
[ __ ] i've heard enough
we now us as the people need to make
sure our government is secure
from these wackadoos these lunatics
and only you can do it and the only way
to do it is to engage in the ballot and
i'm not talking about just marking your
vote
i'm not just talking about going into
the poll and marking your vote i'm
talking about engaging
make sure you talk to people your family
your friends your community like betto's
doing beto's not holding rallies have
you noticed this when he goes it's not
really a rally it's in this i mean these
places are packed and people are
standing out in the overflow
because
it there's enough people to be a rally
but he's at community halls he's at
churches he's in these small little
venues and they're packed to the gills
because he's talking to
his communities
that's what you need to do his
supporters are doing that
there's a sea change folks
i'm telling you it's there we have the
momentum behind us
and there is nothing that is going to
stop these republicans
from being more fascist than they
already are they're saying the quiet
part out loud and they continue jesus
christ you see the list of books they
want to ban in florida they want to ban
a book fair a book fair they want to get
rid of the department of education
we're going to watch a video speaking of
fascist
taking away rights from people we're
going to watch a video of a republican
in south carolina and i'm not going to
go easy on him either
he changed his mind he voted and i
forget his [ __ ] name and it really
doesn't [ __ ] matter at this point
he voted
for the heartbeat bill to take away the
right of women to their bodily autonomy
in south carolina and he regrets it
and he regrets it so he's not voting
he's gonna abstain to a vote to take
away more rights from women
he's just gonna abstain you know he's
not actually gonna
do the thing that he should do and voice
his opinion he's gonna abstain [ __ ]
coward
so we're gonna watch that video we have
a lot of video from mike lindell's
little crazy summit whatever the hell
that wackadoo lunatic conference that is
oh we got a lot of video from that
i think we're gonna have some video of
ron desantis probably queued up
where him and uh pennsylvania's
mussolini i don't know
is he supposed to speak sometime this
morning
with the the the nazi candidate for
governor in pennsylvania
does anybody know i'm not really sure if
he's supposed to speak this morning or
not maybe he will maybe he won't
but ron desantis is making it clear that
he's trying to float
a fascist state all around the country i
told you i just i
keep telling you over and over and over
again doubt me ron desantis is laying
out a blueprint and now he's on the road
he's on a road trip on a on a country
tour to deliver that blueprint to all
the fascists that he thinks can win
their race including in pennsylvania
he's going to go to georgia he's going
to go to several other places he'll
probably end up in all kinds of swing
states as it were
you know he's wanting to box out you
know
the manga king
donald trump
but more than anything the most
important thing is for him to win these
races
and for them to use his blueprint of a
fascist state in florida his
his reign of intolerance
for humans
for education for truth
won't even let people in his rallies
that he knows
that will videotape them
saying intolerant [ __ ]
it's time folks
it's time not yesterday not last week
not last month now is the time to engage
in your democracy now
is the time
we have to lean into this
we have to
january 6 select committee has started
tweeting again over the weekend
you talk about leaning into democracy
there's more hope for the future more
hope for september politicize it that's
right i said it
we have to politicize every single
measure here
your way of life depends on it your
democracy depends on it your children's
way of life depends on it
jesus christ their actual life may
depend on it at this point
it is very important to politicize and
lead into every single issue every last
one of them
i don't care what they call me i don't
care what they say oh tony michaels he
just politicizes everything you goddamn
right i do
like my democracy [ __ ] depends on it
i will you sh
not going to relent you damn right
if you want to if you want to see what
it looks like
for liberalism to take off their gloves
and to fight for their democracy will
come here every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific i'll do it for two [ __ ]
two [ __ ] full hours i'll do it right
here and simulcasting from the midas
touch facebook page
because we will not relent
we won't i won't i know you won't i know
you don't want to give up i know you
want to fight for your way of life you
want to engage in your democracy the
same way people are engaging down in
texas for betto
the same way people are engaging in
pennsylvania for fetterman and ohio for
ryan
for kelly in arizona for warnock and
georgia
for val dimmings in florida it's time
now is the time
to tell intolerance that we will not
tolerate you
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] them
that's the attitude here at the tony
michaels podcast [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore
lost that a long time ago to give a [ __ ]
about rather we're going to politicize
an issue or not
but you can do this too you could do
this too with your family your friends
your community members you do not have
to tolerate their intolerance you can
call it out right on the rug
it's really simple really easy you don't
have to use a bunch of statistics you
don't have to use a bunch of liberal
elitism
you don't have to use a big fancy
college education or a law degree
just common [ __ ] sense
common sense
it's not difficult they want the same
things you want they just think that
it's easier for one person to tell them
what to do
that's what attackers he breeds
and and they're at the front door
knocking the fascists are
again they're running around the country
supporting a bunch of lunatics like
carrie lake this this [ __ ] nazi in
pennsylvania
crazies all over the country
they're supporting
bat [ __ ] crazy
and you might think why in the world
why in the world had they gone down this
rabbit hole well folks
saying the quiet part out loud got a
bunch of violent people to crawl out
underneath their rocks
a bunch of violet white supremacists to
crawl out underneath their rocks
and they also convinced a lot of very
very easily deluded people in this
country especially easily deluded white
people
with russian propaganda and fascist
propaganda that they're somehow getting
their country taken away from them
when they uh they elected and had the
guy in charge that was supposed to
deliver it all back to remember make
america great again well he had his shot
and he [ __ ] trashed it
he [ __ ] trashed it and we know what
republicans do to our democracy we know
what they do to our country we know what
they do to our countrymen we know what
they do to american citizens we know
what they do to hard working middle
class they [ __ ] on them
and they continue to [ __ ] on them
so it's not hard to make this decision
to fight for your democracy
and to engage in the ballot
to make sure
that you're actually doing the thing
called democracy
and having discussions with everyone in
front of you
every single one of them
i was talking to a friend this morning
and they were talking about the fbi
search
and the what about ism from clinton
and the what about ism from obama
and the what about ism
what about what about what about
well how about this
how about this if it is so egregious
what your political enemies did and you
wanted to lock them up
well then why can't we do the same
we should start chanting at events lock
him up
absolutely i mean think about it think
about it
it works to get elected
it got him elected did he lock her up
hell no because there was nothing to
lock her up for
it was all lies but if we do it in truth
if we really do it in earnest
why couldn't that happen
i mean jesus christ he ran on building a
wall couldn't finish the wall couldn't
get mexico to pay for it and here joe
biden got mexico to pay for actual
security at the border
to stop drugs and fentanyl from coming
across the border
like they're bitching about oh my god
did you see
border patrol seized millions of pounds
of fentanyl and they stopped it from
coming across the border
damn you joe biden what are you talking
about
yeah they seized it that's the whole
point
it's all lies it's all lies it's easy to
knock lies it's easy to kill lies come
here come here every single day two
hours a day i kill them all the time
shoot them down bang bang lie bang lie
bang
it's like we're second amendment bros
here shooting down lies
but all you have to do
is use your little your little noggin
there
and to talk to folks i'm not talking
about in a twitter reply thread you're
not going to change you're not going to
change a troll's mind jesus christ
that's what they're there for in the
first place
i'm talking to people who are frustrated
with politics
they're frustrated that people are
taking their rights away
they're frustrated that they see stories
in the news about teenage girls being
forced to give birth
about women losing their bodily autonomy
they thought that would never happen i
mean they just wanted to overturn roe
they didn't actually want the
consequences of it
and they want to go further and they're
not going to stop it they're not going
to stop at book fairs and women's bodily
autonomy folks they're not going to stop
there do you think fashion i mean it's
clear
it's clear that they're not going to
stop there but i mean i i can provide
you evidence all day long
but they're banning math they're banning
book fairs they want to force 10 year
olds
and 16 year olds to have babies jesus
christ in florida ron desantis ron
desantis
is banning book fairs and banning books
and forcing 16 year old girls
to force them to have birth because
they're not mature enough
to decide whether they want to have an
abortion or
not and forget about the parents consent
here they want to take your full consent
away from you about your children that
way in tennessee they can marry them
they had a bill up there trying to marry
children
doubt me
i'm telling you they're not gonna stop
and it's scaring a lot of even
republican politicians because they see
the writing on the wall folks
they see what's happening they watch
what happened in kansas
when kansas went out and not only didn't
vote again for politicians they voted
not to have politicians
take away their [ __ ] rights
that is a slippery slope for a lot of
people it doesn't matter what you
consider yourself politically rather you
think you're [ __ ] democrat republican
you're nonpartisan you're an independent
hell you could be pro-life and go wait a
second you mean there's no exception
none give me a [ __ ] break here
i'm telling you these people are in
trouble and we got them right where we
want them politically
but we have to politicize this thing we
have to
you have to politicize every single
measure and you can not stop you cannot
relent on politicizing it
your way of life your democracy depends
on it because this is the most important
election
that our democracy has come up against
yep i said it this is the most important
one 2020 was the most important one
until it was over
now this is the most important one until
this one's over and then it'll be the
next one and the next one and the next
one they're not going anywhere
you think you think mike lindell
marjorie taylor green steve bannon
donald trump ron desantis are gonna stop
the grift stop the fascist grift you
think lauren beaubert's gonna give up
strutting around on stage raising money
jesus christ ron desantis can't raise
[ __ ] money from stall small donors
anymore so he's going to big big paydays
big the donor class
because he can't get small donations
anymore
we got him where we want him we just
gotta lean into it just [ __ ] lean
into it
and don't quit
we can't go up we won that one
so we're done now
we have to keep going we have to keep
spreading the pro-democracy message
look the tail always wags the dog in
this country
it always does
this idea that somehow a transformative
politician
dilutes the masses is absolutely [ __ ]
ridiculous that is not how it works that
is never how it works it may appear that
way but that is not it
that is not it the tail always wags the
dog
always you see it in texas
you see it in texas texans are [ __ ]
ready for someone who's gonna fight for
them
and betto is genuine about caring about
his community
so yes the tail wagging the dog there of
course it is sure why not why shouldn't
the tail wag the dog
why shouldn't politicians do what we the
constituents the government we're the
government not them they're just the
elected officials of the government we
are the government
we get to wag the [ __ ] dog
we are the tail
so be the tail be the tail that wags the
dog politicize the [ __ ] out of
everything all of it every all up and
down that [ __ ] you're never
going to get the line items you want
you're never going to get the line items
you want you want to get rid of this you
want to get rid of that you want to add
this you want to have this
well if you let the fascists take
control
if you don't fight hard
for democracy because democracy is tough
folks it's a [ __ ]
democracy's a [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] to come to a
consensus with a large group of people
wouldn't you say why do you think why do
you think the democratic party is always
in disarray that's what they say and the
democratic party isn't in disarray
we just all don't agree on every single
measure and we sit and fight over it
when what we should be doing is going
hey they're fascists we're not going to
put up with that why don't we band
together
and fight that
and then we'll then we'll once we once
we have made the fascists crawl back
underneath their rocks then we'll fight
over what the actual amount of minimum
wage should be because then we'll have
control policy maybe then we'll we'll
argue when children should start start
school at three or at five
maybe that's a policy we'll fight over
once we get rid of the fascist out of
the government they want to make
marjorie taylor green the speaker of the
house
they want to make marjorie taylor green
the speaker of the house and i'm sure
i'm sure lauren bobert
will be the whip
oh my god that's where we're at folks
that's where we're headed you are the
only thing that can stop it doubt me
speaking and doubt me we got to doubt me
merch everyone's been calling for it
clamoring for the doubt be merch please
please please get here it is it's live
folks go to store.thetonymichaels.com
the mods have the link in the chat
you can go to thetonymichaels.com you
can click on the merch store as well
the merch is here also support pro
democracy speech today i would love i
would love if you guys showed support
for our show you can do that at
support.tonymichaelspod.com
we keep it going two hours every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central i do not want to stop
yelling into this microphone
so we support we we appreciate your
support and we support democracy and we
support pro-democracy speech here on the
tony michaels podcast
so make sure to not just support us
though support other pro-democracy
speech out there and it's not always
about giving money i mean if you got a
little bit to give to pro-democracy
speech whether it be us whether it be
other folks in the midas touch network
or outside that network or even your
politicians that you think can win these
races
they
they need that change it costs money
unfortunately in this society it costs
money to perpetuate the speech and to
perpetuate the change in elections
to get to where we can set policy so do
those things support pro-democracy and
i'm not just talking about cash
i'm talking about liking sharing finding
those things talking to your neighbors
your friends your community members
as
as these pro-democracy candidates are
doing all around the country
we got a lot of [ __ ] around to round up
today you know we surf the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends every single
weekday here on the tony michaels
podcast and when we come back
we got a lot of video to go through so
don't go anywhere the [ __ ] list roundup
is right up next stick around we'll be
right back right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your part in blanket
today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
marjorie taylor green is going to be the
speaker of the house
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
jesus christ are you kidding me
[Music]
i guess that was the big piece of
information that mike lindell said we
were all going to love
he's running some kind of i don't know
cyber shintosim or i don't know what the
[ __ ] they're doing there's having some
kind of crazy fascist nazi rally down in
springfield missouri because they
couldn't find anywhere else but this was
supposed to be the world's biggest event
there's going to be so many millions of
people here he's barely at a thousand
people watching this [ __ ] thing but
you got to keep an eye on this because
they're projecting what they want to do
you have to take them seriously when
they say what they want
they're saying the quiet part out loud
of course they are why wouldn't they
there's no fear anymore
again when the when the fascist tail is
wagging the dog
when the when the nazis the america
first nazi party crawls out underneath
their rocks of course of course
why not
why not just go to pennsylvania ron
desantis
and christened the mango mussolini's
pick
for governor there the nazi
oh boy if you're not paying attention
you need to you need to get with it
because here we go let's surf the tweety
tweets in the trendy trends because i
got some video to show you let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
the shitless ground up welcome to the
part of the show where we surf the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends this
will not disappoint today you're gonna
have plenty plenty of ammunition when
you leave here today to talk to your
family and friends and tell them how
absolutely [ __ ] luna out the lunacy
of the right is out in full force
and they're ready they're ready to take
over the government and turn it into a
fascist christian white national estate
the christian white nationalist herself
marjorie taylor green you see here is at
mike lindell's lying conference a nazi
rally down in springfield missouri
with with the king of the mogalodites
the pipe piper of the mongolite steve
bannon
isn't steve supposed to go to prison
soon
and he's supposed to go to prison soon
now maybe these other two on the [ __ ]
stage can go to prison too
i don't know i'm just saying i don't
know what what do you think gabe sanchez
do you think you think these uh these
three um need to be handcuffed i know
i'm just
i i would totally agree that they do you
think these i mean you got steve bannon
who's definitely probably gonna go to
jail um you got marjorie taylor green
which she has she has she doesn't even
know how to govern because she's not
even in committees like she's right
she didn't know how to committee and and
and steve bannon
is telling uh
the crowd here the the tens of people
that showed up at the nazi rally in
springfield missouri for the level nazi
uh to have i don't know some kind of
revelation is going to change our minds
i guess it's this revelation where steve
bannon is saying we're going to make
marjorie taylor green the speaker of the
house that's a big revelation that's
going to change the country yeah i
actually think that it should this piece
of clip watch this have you seen this
yet
i i saw a thumbnail i have not actually
watched okay well i know it's going to
be [ __ ] dumb this is this is not very
long i won't even pause it interrupt i
promise
i will play the whole clip here let's
let's watch
and once we win the house
do we have a better speaker of the house
than mtg
oh that's [ __ ] disgusting
look at that
that's amazing
are we going to need her as speaker the
house to take it to the democrats
all right
even mike glendale's not sure right he's
like um he's looking at his watch he's
like holy [ __ ] that is not the piece of
information that i expected to come out
of my rally yeah molly it's okay let's
also let's also work let's say let's
remind ourselves here last year
michael and dell held the mike lindell's
cyber symposium is that not what this is
i thought this was what this is dude
this is the same thing right rebranded
oh so he's giving the same evidence that
didn't exist it's this it's more or less
the same evidence this single [ __ ]
same boy
you know the cyber symposium last year
that's the one that got tina peters uh
indicted on federal charges because mike
lindell talked her into [ __ ] around
with voting machines and [ __ ] right and
that was the one this year where
they're like you can't go
because that was i think it was the
judge this year that was like you can't
go to this thing right you're talking
about tina tina peters yeah yeah well
because what if you remember the cyber
symphonies remember he's supposed to
have some kind of crazy it was gonna be
a groundbreaking guest and she was going
to lift the lid off everything and
that's who it was was tina peters and
who is who lauren bobert supports by the
way she's in colorado same district uh
one of the county officials in lauren
bobert's district and i'm not sure if
they redistrict if we get changed but
anyways the point is that person is on
on federal indictment for for
fraudulently messing with voting
machines and taking voter information
but she was they they even described it
at the cyber symposium i remember that
she comes out on stage she's talking
about how they had to fly around in a
plane so they didn't arrest her and [ __ ]
and she was gonna come here to tell
everyone exactly what happened before
she got arrested
and i don't know it's just kind of funny
she knew she was committing crime she
knew she was gonna get arrested but they
tried to frame it up like it was the
deep state same [ __ ] they're doing with
this [ __ ] classified document [ __ ]
yeah it's so i mean like you know
they're admitting to the crimes i mean
you had cash patel yesterday or two days
ago i got that clip go ahead yeah and
and just kind of goes yeah well i saw
him he he declassified everything it's
like whoa whoa
you were there you you witnessed this
you saw him
declassify these documents and he's
talking about the magic wand kind of
thing right he's like the one you're
talking about yeah it's like um guardian
declassification or something like that
you know
right
is there like a declassification seance
that these people hold i think so i
think basically they sit in a circle
and they pray to ronald reagan
and they pray to
uh which is kind of funny which is kind
of yeah yeah they have these people and
they're trying you know reagan and nixon
and uh you know george h.w bush and they
kind of throw in and occasionally
they'll throw lincoln and lincoln's
always like nah [ __ ] this science i'm
out of here like he doesn't even want to
be a part of that but every time they
just try to they try to throw this
seance and they try to
do some magic right because they're like
we're witches and warlocks and that's
what we do
[ __ ] it really it really is weird
that the white christian nationalists
are totally into like pagan stuff you
know they're gonna have a seance here is
here's your tweet about cash patel here
um and cash patel says in december and
january on the way out like he's
admitting it here on the way out like
they're saying we knew
we knew we needed these documents to
hold them as evidence or sell them or
some [ __ ] i don't know yeah he witnessed
donald trump declassifying whole he says
whole sets of documents yeah like
there's just like a pile of documents
like it's [ __ ] costco bulk style and
he's like declassified right
declassified well he also claims that
that the tweets are proper
declassification yeah
i find that hilarious they're like via
social media
like social media is the is the magic
wand a waving tool that says if you go i
declassify and then it's like well he
put it on truth social he played online
he made it he look he made he made a
press statement about it and and release
it online
everything makes it official
you know like the um they they had this
problem early on in his administration
when he basically threw lgbtq people in
the military under the bus right
and he said we will not you know
and basically the department of defense
is like what the hell is this i mean
they really had to go through a there
was a legal process that they had to go
to to figure out
like
do we follow this is this an order what
the hell is this like they weren't
really sure but listen to cash patel
tell the story here now remember
cash patel is not only a moguladay this
guy was in charge of [ __ ] at the
department of defense on the day
of january 6 when they tried to
violently overthrow our government
listen required that is a fiction being
created by the fake news and the radical
left in october of 2020 president trump
put out i'm going to point something out
here do you see his pen on his coat yeah
the cash pin yeah what the hell is that
i don't know [ __ ] k-s-h but cash is
like a money sign right right yeah is
that like is that like does he have his
own you know they all got their own
traitor bitcoin or some [ __ ] yeah like
his own is that what he's doing like i
was curious about this last night and
i think it's
because he's a [ __ ] trader well the
other thing about trader is trader
social or fraud social as i normally
refer to it did you see the video of
cash patel and devin nunes trying to
pimp this like laser truth oh yeah
oh that's hilarious yeah like they like
they're they're making so much money
over their true social that their ideas
depend like my only so i can't find
anything online that actually has the k
dollar sign h but it doesn't make sense
because the way that that would be that
would that would sound right is
like is it
a dollar sign doesn't make an as
no sound well i mean i would understand
if he would say k a dollar sign h that
would make sense
yeah yeah i thought that maybe that's
why it was some kind of symbol for like
a bitcoin or some [ __ ] i don't know
i have no idea i was like oh i don't
know if this is some sort like at first
when i thought i was like oh is that
like a cash app like
like that's his username on cash app
like is that what he's trying to get
like money there i don't know i know but
then when i try to look it up like
google knows what i'm i'm looking for
but they don't know
even google's like even google's like
this is so stupid i don't even know like
we we think we know
oh it's just his logo okay i want it no
it's his logo so this is like a don jr
thing because don jr has the stupid gold
logo and cash patel apparently has an
even dumber logo
yeah it's just his uh
it's really confusing there's a website
selling hoodies tank tops and other gear
with his logo oh
yeah okay well that's that's good to
know well let's let's let's finish it
let's get to the trader part of this
clip not the uh
not the cash logo part of it for the
world to see a sweeping declassification
order and he did it via social media
every single russia gateway
this is the social media part so he he
he goes on here about all these
documents that he's declassifying and
the reason why he's saying this [ __ ] is
because number one he knows that's not
how this works he knows that all those
documents that he's about to list off
and you know puke out of his mouth
that's not gonna declassify these
documents it's not outworks and the only
reason why they pretend that they
declassify these things is to say that
they're transparent this is the [ __ ]
that this administration and the media
still buys into
he would come out we remember when he
was the [ __ ] he tried to be the
dictator of our country he would come
out and go to his helicopter as he was
walking to his helicopter he would puke
lies to the media and they would air it
on tv and they act like he's being
transparent like what do you talk just
because he lies into a microphone
doesn't mean he's being transparent
transparent
is the actual
the actual
uh
act of showing the truth that's
transparency
hiding the truth with lies is the
opposite of transparency cash
or or however you say your logo name i
don't know me is cash
single hillary gate doc every one those
are his words that is the precedent that
the president united states is allowed
to operate under and then in december in
january
yeah i witnessed him declassify
wholesale no you did
i mean i i actually think he's lying
here don't you oh yeah yeah there's no
yeah he is i don't think he's telling
this but here's the thing even if he
what like either way he's telling the
truth or he's not telling the truth he
just admitted on tv right
that he saw this that he witnesses which
means that now
like as if he wasn't already a person
person of interest he is definitely
someone like oh so you saw him do this
we want to know more about that who was
in the room when did he do it where did
you do it what documents was he
declassifying because they're probably
going to check and say like all right
were the clock were the documents that
he declassified that day that you
witnessed are they the same documents
that we were covered or are they still
missing
well this bonehead too also
when he's saying this because i think
he's lying here there was no there was
no situation where donald trump is like
waving his hands over a box of documents
saying i declassify you that's all
[ __ ] but i do believe this is that
painting you know that painting with
jesus where he has his hand over yeah
right yeah just like that and then it
just it's just like transitive property
jesus is actually declassifying the
documents that may be what it is
white nationalist
declassification through jesus
with the bridge of trump but here's the
thing i do believe him when he's saying
he was in the room when donald trump was
packing this [ __ ] up oh yeah that's the
thing that i think is most important
about this little
situation that cash patel has put
himself in is cash mattel definitely was
there to witness donald trump
mishandling classified documents 100
percent and i wouldn't be surprised if
cash patel is packing this [ __ ] in boxes
with it
and that's what he means like yeah i was
there hell yeah i was there in the room
with him when there was
[ __ ]
dozens of boxes of classified documents
right of course i was like
i think that might be why i don't know
if cash patel isn't the informant a lot
of folks including michael cohen is
saying that it's jared but
how do we know that it's not cash patel
and really i think that should be
the main question that people keep
asking donald trump is cash patel the
fbi informant here yeah i mean if cash
patel is going out on national
television saying that i watched donald
trump handle classified documents i
watched him pack him away he was
standing in front of a mountain of
classified documents
i don't know i i mean that's enough
evidence for me to believe that cash
patel it's also an interesting play to
be like i'm the informant and i'm going
to go out and act like i'm not the
informant that's right continuing to
push this idea that oh yeah he just
waved his hand and it was declassify
that and to classify that and glassed by
that the other thing that i was thinking
about yesterday was
so if you're at a company
you had a job you know and let's say
they have layoffs or you're fired right
you have to
leave the property the premises that day
they will say great we shut down your
access to all these accounts your
computer
you pack up your [ __ ] into a box the
things that you own which is like oh i
had a little plant and i had a little
like some pens and peppers
yeah yeah but everything else is like
this is our ip this is our property this
is what we own so in this moment like i
know that she is what happened here is
like trump didn't quit right he wasn't
like all right i'm i'm out i'm retiring
i'm resigning whatever he was fired
right this was a moment of like yeah we
fight people
the american people voted and they and
they said you're fired to donald trump
you fired uh by over seven million votes
over seven million people said you're
fired you know
so
what happens
is we think hey any adult in the past
has normally handled their uh their
their their transfer of power in a
respectable professional way and trump's
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm gonna take
whatever i can and i'm because it what
happens is
trump now has
says spite out against the government
against the american people because he
says oh well you know what if i can't
have it neither can he
neither can you right he's the kid that
has the ball and he takes it home with
him because he loses the game or or
something happens where he's like oh you
know [ __ ] this i'm taking the ball back
home with me he got his ass kicked by
dark brandon on the playground exactly
what happened and so right now you look
at this and i was trying to think i was
like oh if any sort of professional
company setting
you would get all access removed they'd
be like nope you're a threat you're a
risk especially if someone holds a
grudge and they have certain level of
authority or like power at a company
they could do severe damage and here you
have the ceo of the company that is
america and we're like yeah we trust him
to do what he should do we trust him to
be an adult and that is where we [ __ ]
up this is one of those things he was
like nah we should have we should have
had some sort of like security person
that was there making sure that this
[ __ ] was done right
and now because
this happened we probably will have to
make a new set of rules
for this transfer of power it's like
when you go into a restaurant or a
business and somebody has a sign up that
says don't do this thing it's because
somebody did that thing and they're like
well [ __ ] now we have to make a sign to
say don't do this thing because you made
the assumption that everyone's gonna be
an adult and not do this thing
well you know you see you see these
stupid stickers on the like machinery
like don't stick your hand in this thing
like yeah that's right it seems that
seems that seems but it only takes one
person to [ __ ] it up for everyone where
it's like oh god okay who was the
dumbass that put their hand in that
thing right right well let's let's
listen to this dumbass who walks
straight into the actual point here
again they do this all the time but
let's see how he tries to weed his way
out of it it is not incumbent upon
president trump and his lawyers and his
and and henny as a target of this
investigation to show he in fact did
declassify them it's up to the
government who has the burden of proof
who are trying to deprive a man of his
liberty to show that no such order was
in fact given they actually that's not
that's not what they have to do they
just they don't have to show whether he
did or did not classify him that's all
[ __ ] they just have to show what the
documents actually are that's it there
is a fact of what the documents are if
he didn't go through the proper protocol
for the government to know exactly how
he wanted the classification of those
documents that's his [ __ ] problem not
the government's he was carrying these
things still marked the way they were
supposed to be marked that is the point
too
and i think that's really what the
sticking point is gonna be here because
we're gonna watch the january six select
committee um start their hearing soon
gabe they've been tweeting like a
[ __ ] i think we're gonna get an
announcement probably this week of when
these hearings are supposed to be i
don't know that i don't have any
evidence other than that they've been
tweeting ramping up this storyline again
against donald trump but i think
actually this document story is is going
to be the least of trump's worries about
these classified documents how he
handled them rather he sold them i
actually think that's gonna be the least
of his worries here because there was a
lot of missing documents when the
january 6 select committee and the doj
went and subpoenaed the white house for
a lot of records including logs um
certain notes and things and who knows
maybe those are just some of the
documents that that they're trying to
hide from the american people and
because the january 6 committee they
went to the doj and they said hey can we
have these can we have access to these
documents after nara came out and said
hey we've collected 15 boxes the january
16th this was the original boxes yeah
these are the original ones and the
january 6 came out a committee came out
and said hey can we get access to those
documents because we want to see if
there's anything in there
that would give us insight into what
happened on january 6th and the doj doj
was like nope
access denied like you cannot have it
right now at the time we just assumed
that everything was collected because
doj subpoenaed those boxes from nara the
name right exactly
and so this is one of those moments
where like wait why like there's an
investigation but it seems weird that it
was just like flat out denied and so now
it all makes sense because they're like
well they were [ __ ] skiff documents
classified documents top secret
documents that no one should have their
hands on outside of certain uh personnel
or certain areas like just you know
right it's not supposed to even leave a
certain type of [ __ ] room right like
so now so now you're like oh this makes
total sense it wasn't just like no you
can't have it because you can't have it
it was like you can't have it because
well we can't give it to you yeah we
can't give it to you and also we're
still missing parts of those things and
we're still trying to figure out where
the [ __ ] they are and what happened to
them
right and that's and that's and that's
why
yeah that's why cash is kind of in a
between a rock and a hard spot here
let's finish up they no they can't so
what happens the fake news mafia comes
in and says
oh but there was no protocols followed
and mark you know when they're arguing
protocols and procedure
it's because they have lost the factual
argument and the truth and now they are
trying to hide behind this magistrate
judge who is going to supposedly play
this game of redactions we oh that's
hilarious so and we we've watched this
morning i think the magistrate announced
this morning that they're not gonna
he may he may still do some redacting
and release this affidavit but he's not
at this time that affidavit isn't gonna
come public like the uh
like the news media wants which really
honestly we shouldn't be having uh this
affidavit out in the public without
heavy consideration of what what this
act what the ramifications of this is i
think this judge is gonna make the right
decision it looked like he was gonna go
in the way of trump here but you have to
remember trump's attorneys didn't even
say anything in this meeting they filed
no real motion um they keep saying
they're going to they keep threats
this is all the same [ __ ] that rudy
giuliani said he's like oh we've got
affidavits and he goes we got stacks of
affidavits and he's got papers in his
hand doesn't mean [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like
we got evidence on tv saying this stuff
and then we find out in the january 6
committee it's not evidence they're just
theories
they're just [ __ ] theories they're
like well i think
somebody put a suitcase with ballots in
i think
we saw this on the on on the footage and
turns out it's all lies and they're
pushing this narrative and it's the same
thing here they go on to newsmax and
they go on to oan and they're like look
we have evidence that shows that they
planted the evidence at mar-a-lago right
we have evidence that this is illegal
and it violates the fourth amendment
which they don't know what type of
certificate seizures right yeah it's
like i mean they're starting they're
starting to get a constitutional
education with this guy committing all
the crimes you have to use his
constitutional rights to try to block
self-incrimination here well they're
trying to learn they're starting to
learn the constitution aren't they
they're also they're also starting to
learn to say like oh look uh yep i lost
my law degree like i've been disbarred
right because they decided to double
down and say yeah well they can use
their freedom of speech they can use
their freedom of speech but there is
consequences of that especially when
you're a lawyer speaking of people going
on news organizations and lying here is
here is jake tapper and again i don't
understand why these [ __ ] have
people like dan crenshaw i guess because
he spoke out against you know his party
once so they have him on because you
know he must not be a liar but here he
is [ __ ] lying his eye patch off let's
watch
well look you know me jake and i'm not
one to withhold criticism uh and even
make my own side mad i i want to get to
the truth and but i will be honest with
you here it this
it's hard to justify what the department
of justice did here in my opinion okay
well your opinion [ __ ] sucks dan yeah
it's it's [ __ ] it's absolute a big pile
of [ __ ] your opinion that is
so here's my suggestion why don't you
get a [ __ ] glass eye and [ __ ] off
this guy who claims that performing
politics and all this [ __ ] here he
is suckling at the teat of this trump
lie
he knows it's all [ __ ]
this guy wasn't this guy an intelligence
officer at some point
intelligence officer all right here
let's see the guy pro the guy definitely
knows
how to handle or how you're supposed to
handle classified information and what
it means to actually declassify a piece
of information i'm sure
yeah he was this he was on seal team
three
warren afghanistan
oh senate commander this must be one of
the seals that is donald don jr's
friends huh yeah must be one of the
seals that he gave during that speech i
got a i got friends who were steals
that's that's he doesn't have he doesn't
have friends come on let alone seals he
doesn't have friends does he die yeah
yeah no he has he has no he has he calls
you all the time but i know he does he
called me he actually called me uh
the other day about uh did you read it
did you i did i did i'm
um
but dan crenshaw like this guy is openly
admitting to saying yes
is it wrong to take the documents no
question that should that is not right
however this is a very political move by
the doj no it's not
no it is not
you're talking you're you're you're
admitting
that it's illegal to take these things
all right he doesn't say illegal he says
it's not right i think is what he said
and then he goes further to say
with that being said
i think they're overreacting about him
taking these classified documents which
it's not especially when we've realized
that these are
highly classified documents they contain
nuclear secrets uh and that's all that
we actually know about there's probably
even more [ __ ] that's in there that's
more top secret that no one can know
but the fact that he's like yeah yeah
yeah it's wrong however
let's just understand that this is a
political move by the doj no it's not
you would do the same [ __ ] [ __ ] if
some dem if biden decided hey look
precedent has been this has been
established and i'm going to take these
documents to my home in delaware and i'm
going to create the [ __ ]
they would [ __ ] lose their [ __ ]
[ __ ] can you hear me like we need the
head of biden that's what they would say
they imagine the
can you imagine if there was a dark
brandon scrapbook
that would be
that might be that might maybe you know
what maybe
maybe he stole the dark brandon
scrapbook and that's in those boxes i
don't know i'm just saying i don't know
i mean there's like photos of him
you know getting ice cream right there's
photos of him on a bike
there's photos of him holding up
documents
you know also earlier you said you know
maybe these were the seals that uh that
don or that don jr was friends with yeah
and i think that it's not it's not
actual people he might be talking about
like like actually oh
like he went to like a zoo
or like a like an aquarium you know that
makes sense that makes sense that makes
sense maybe him and eric uh tried to get
his dad to go to to go to sea world with
him and he wouldn't go
but they made friends with some seals
let's listen that's what i think he
meant what where is this this is this is
some event um some something carolina
let's see okay well this is probably
some kind of event where they're they're
supporting a not america first nazi um
probably a member of the america first
nazi party trying to take over part of
our government and trying to turn it
into a fascist state i'd imagine i mean
i can only there's only so many things
the reason why don jr would travel
across country to spread fascism or to
score some coke but let's listen to john
here the donny jr booger sugar junior
fantasize about having friends
let alone in our melody i have friends
on seal teams that tell me they spend
more time now
in diversity
training then they do shooting and i was
also like this is one of them
okay so there's a lot of problems with
this don number one everyone knows you
don't have [ __ ] friends everyone
knows that
but here's the other thing is he's like
oh
now now that joe biden actually did the
thing that my dad promised to get us out
of the war in afghanistan these guys
don't have anyone to shoot and kill so
tolerance is the thing that they're
teaching these people this is more of
this stupid [ __ ] wokism [ __ ] it's uh
the person that he
because on i was as i was looking at the
signs sorry it's friends of carolina
or carolina i don't know i don't know
okay you pronounce their name oh so this
isn't like the state of carolina known
as her name friends of
carolina carolina i'm not sure uh
amnesty
welcome to the fundraising reception
with donald trump jr friends of of
carolina amnesty state house candidate
district 45
august 18 2022
she's running in the state of florida
for district
45. okay so so this is important
because you have don jr
the the coked up son
of the former guy
going to a state house race is that
right is that what you're saying yeah
yeah at state house race in florida
if you're not engaged in your democracy
and you're not paying attention to some
of your local races
these fascists are trying to take your
[ __ ] local district away from you and
they're gonna try to use their fascism
to take away your way of life in these
local districts don jr is showing up
booger sugar junior and i'm sure he's
you know he probably went there because
he could score some decent coke in that
town or some [ __ ]
but they're they're out for blood i'm
telling you they're out for blood
um and and these state races are
important let me show you why this
happened in south carolina i believe
this was the end of last week this guy's
name is collins
again this is in south carolina
in the uh i believe in their house their
house chamber um because he's a
representative he's not a senator here
so it would be reflective of their house
chamber in the state of carolina i'm not
sure exactly how their legislators made
up in carolina but this is an elected
official now he is but he voted to take
away women's rights in a personhood bill
he describes it here and then he starts
to talk about how he almost immediately
regrets it now
i'm gonna rip this [ __ ] apart
because i actually think we should not
give this son of a [ __ ] any kind of
credit here [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him and anyone who thinks like him
at this point everyone's like oh well we
should invite them over to our side our
side [ __ ] you this guy abstained from
another vote that took it even further
even after he made this speech he didn't
vote against that bill he abstained and
by abstaining he's only [ __ ] giving
credence to their bigotry and their and
their [ __ ] fascism here but listen to
how he regrets his vote because he
didn't fully understand the
ramifications of him voting for
legislation this is the most boneheaded
[ __ ] thing i have ever heard in my
life that a politician doesn't
understand that when they vote on
[ __ ] legislation that it affects
their constituents you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's listen
i'll move to
my final comments then mr chairman
i voted for the pain-capable bill
the fetal heartbeat bill
and fetal heartbeat has been
for
six weeks now
neil collins is this guy's name by the
way
representative neil collins and notice
he's on the judiciary special laws
committee this [ __ ] the second
week
that this that the fetal heartbeat bill
became law
a doctor called me
out of anderson i live in easley
a 19 year old girl
appeared at the er
she was 50. so now a 19 year old's a
girl by the way
now to them a 19 year old's a girl
well she's you know she's a teenager so
she's still a girl i mean i would agree
but now to them now they're changing
their mind yeah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] here 15 weeks pregnant
her water broke
and the the fetus was unviable
the standard of care was to advise her
uh that they could extract
or she could go home
the attorneys told the doctors that
because of the fetal heartbeat bill
because that 15 week old had a heartbeat
the doctors could not extract so their
only choices were to
now you notice because
this is why i think this motherfucker's
a coward he's a [ __ ] coward
now he's sitting here and he's saying
these things and people are like well at
least he had the he had the gumption to
speak up here well frankly he did a
dereliction in duty by speaking up like
this and then abstaining from a vote
against what he uh what he's saying is
gonna harm his constituents here he's a
weak piece of [ __ ] and frankly in my
mind he didn't go far enough uh someone
who wasn't a coward would not only speak
spoke up but use their vote in support
of their [ __ ] constituents but you
notice how he blames it he blames it on
the attorneys did you see that did you
notice that little
thing there well yeah i mean they're
never gonna take they're never gonna
take uh responsibility they're never
gonna say hey
look i won didn't read the bill when i
voted on it two i never really thought
of what the
outcomes or possibilities or like edge
cases could be if somebody was pregnant
despite the fact that there were other
people on the other side of the aisle
that said you haven't thought this
[ __ ] thing through
and when it does come back to bite you
in the ass
you're gonna you're not gonna be able to
point fingers because you were the one
who voted on it you're the one who put
your stamp of approval to say yes it
should be illegal after six weeks to
have an abortion and now
you have someone that's just a county
over just a town over whatever and you
feel for that person but you have just
no ability despite the fact that you
have the power to now vote against it
you go
yeah yeah i did i would i would love to
vote against it but i can't because i
would get torched rebecca on um
facebook points out and she says what
the [ __ ]
you can't go home after your water
breaks you can get an infection and or
is harmful to the baby yeah
that's the thing that's the thing here
the republicans want to force the
doctors to not do the thing that i don't
know they were educated do which is
medicine and send these women home with
this fear of infection and dying watch
admit the 19 year old until that fetal
heartbeat stopped i asked how long does
it take to stop
she said
seconds minutes hours maybe days or
discharge
they discharge that 19 year old
the doctor told me at that point there's
a 50 chance well first
she's going to pass this fetus in the
toilet
she's going to have to deal with that on
her own
there's a 50 chance greater than 50
chance that she's going to lose her
uterus there's a 10 chance that she will
develop sepsis and herself die
that weighs on me i voted for that bill
these are affecting people
oh oh my god
can you imagine can you imagine bill
a bill
a bill affecting people gabe if you vote
on let you are you telling me that
that's what policy and government does
are you telling me that when we elect
these officials to make decisions for us
us the government when they represent us
as the government you mean the decisions
and the votes that they take affect us
are you serious this is ridiculous how
[ __ ] how ridiculous is this that
these people have to weigh this on their
mind yeah
it's crazy that uh you know just like
trump's lawyers learning about
constitutional law
it's almost like these people who are in
office are like getting like a civics
lesson and understanding how policy
making is done and that when you vote on
something it's not just for you to say
well it doesn't affect me so i don't
give a [ __ ] but now that you have
constituents or people that are coming
to you and saying that you're like oh i
feel for that person because yeah it is
incredibly [ __ ] up that somebody would
have to have a an uh you know can't get
an abortion even though that is the
recommended procedure when you have this
happen to you and they say nope you know
what you have to now keep that dead
dead
fetus
in your body
and you could possibly die you get
sepsis you get an infection
uh you can get sick right like you your
health is at risk so because of the baby
or the the fetus
you know
stopped and and your and your body was
like hey look this is this is not going
to
not going to work out republicans like
nope got to keep it that's how [ __ ] up
that is and this guy's like oh man like
this is so messed up yeah what the [ __ ]
did you think was going to happen when
you decided to say six weeks was the
bare minimum or rather the maximum of
when you could get an abortion i mean
here's the thing the reason why he
really is upset gabe the reason why he's
upset is not because of the life of this
19 year old that has nothing to do with
it not because other people could be
affected he's affected by this and the
reason why he's affected by this is
because he was roped into these
conversations and now he's in a position
where he has to defend his vote how dare
you how dare you
as constituents get me in a situation
where i now have to defend my vile vote
to take your rights away what the hell's
wrong with you don't if you are
affecting me because that's really what
he's saying here right listen to the end
here this affects him that's why he's
pissed off here that's why i don't give
a [ __ ] about this guy i don't care what
the [ __ ] story he told the way he told
it here it's about him the whole [ __ ]
thing is about him well he's the victim
tony he's absolutely no responsibility
i'm the victim i feel the pain even
though this
this teenage 19 year old girl was the
one who had to go through this very
traumatic physical and emotional just
stress and trauma and he goes meh well
yeah [ __ ] it
that is what it is someone's asking he
abstained yes he does abstain you'll see
the end of the clip where he says he's
going to abstain watch
and we're having a meeting about this
it took
that whole week i did not sleep
see wow see i told you this [ __ ]
i followed up with the doctor a week
later yeah she had heard nothing
did not know about the 19 year old
thank god i followed up two weeks later
she did return to the er they did
extract the now non-beating fetus
thank god they did an abortion on here
do you hear this guy yeah you hear this
[ __ ]
this forced birther thank god he says
because i was losing sleep oh my god
well well well thank god for
representative collins that this that
this 19 year old girl finally was able
to get a medical procedure to save her
life because he voted for a [ __ ] bill
and and he couldn't get sleep since he
voted for it this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him and anyone like him
[ __ ] him everyone hailed this guy over
the weekend and he's some kind of
[ __ ] hero for speaking out he's not
speaking out for her he's speaking out
for himself [ __ ] yeah again it is all
the it is the projection it is the guilt
it is the gaslighting it is i'm the
victim
i'm the one who really experienced the
trauma and i want to say that in order
for me to sleep well at night
i abstain
i am staying tony here here he is and it
cleanses just like [ __ ] clean slate i
abstain it's like you go to church and
you're like forgive me father for i've
sinned and then a church and then the
priest says okay let me get 10 hail
marys and uh five our fathers and you
should be good and you're like okay cool
awesome well here it is here here is
here's his here's his conscience being
cleared here
what we do matters
thank you oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] one second
mr chairman i'm almost finished shut the
[ __ ] up out of respect for the process
i'm not voting today
but i want it to be
clear
that myself and many others are not
in a position to vote for this bill
without significant changes
i'm not in a position to vote today i
abstain yeah what a pile of [ __ ] he's
crying he's crying because of a decision
he made
you made this decision we people have
been saying this about this [ __ ] for
decades and decades and decades if you
go down the slippery slope it will cost
people their [ __ ] lives
it'll cost them their lives it's not
some kind of [ __ ] liberal [ __ ]
conspiracy
theory where we're trying to make you
have a certain religion or force you to
have abortions you are forcing people to
have birth you are forced birthers you
are not pro-life yeah you are not
pro-life collins and you still are not
pro-life you are still a force birther
because you abstain you won't show your
voice to make sure to protect that 19
year old and and women like her and
their bodily autonomy and their privacy
to make decisions that could save or
affect their life
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] him i
don't i don't i don't want to hear
anyone talking about how much of a hero
this guy is [ __ ] and i think i think
the part of the video that that almost
pissed me off on like as much as him
saying despite me saying this very very
sad and
and you know realistic but depressing
story about this young girl having to go
through this event this dramatic event
it's the woman next to him that like
consoles him
and i'm like are you [ __ ] serious
right now [ __ ] that [ __ ] like going one
going against your own side like as a
woman that you're like oh yeah yeah well
it really [ __ ] sucks for that girl
and this woman's like oh you're oh my
god i'm sorry like are you gonna tear up
i'm here let me just let me just like
brush your shoulder and your arm give me
a [ __ ] break dude poor guy like what
a poor guy he lost sleep gabe he lost
sleep i can't imagine one
week oh my god he lost sleep for one
week let alone all the women out there
who can't make [ __ ] medical decisions
about their goddamn body
like he he's upset for one week he's
like i couldn't sleep i lost sleep for a
week oh my god and then he tells a story
like
like originally when i heard this video
and he was like oh i followed up with
the doctor and the doctor didn't hear
anything a week went by
and the worst thought in my mind
happened which was that the girl didn't
survive right she got an infection she
died or something very terrible happened
right because her life was at risk she
was carrying a
dead fetus in her body that could hurt
her own health
and so when he originally said oh i
followed up and the doctor didn't hurt
hear from her i was like oh [ __ ] yeah
you're thinking
you're thinking i was like the story is
going not the way that i want so when i
hear him say oh i lost sleep for a week
well imagine if this girl had lost sleep
well for the rest of her life because
she died
and he goes
well and it's likely
it's likely with this with them not
being able to make this procedure and
and discharging her it is likely that
she will never be able to have children
talk about talk about being pro-life
talk about being pro-fucking life
and then and then he has the goal to
thank god that's what pisses me off the
most when he thanks god that they were
able to do that that abortion you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] you piece of vile trash
when you when you tell when you tell
people they can or cannot make a choice
about their goddamn body and their
health care and their [ __ ] well-being
in their life and then you thank god
that they had an abortion because you
used your [ __ ] god
you used your [ __ ] god to tell them
they can't do that you piece of vile
trash speaking of vile trash invoking
god you were talking about um people
praying to god
and
someone deeming them um absolvent of
their sins this is hilarious this is
again at this um whatever the hell this
thing is the moment of truth oh that's
that's what it is uh yeah hosted by mike
lindell so what do are they calling this
the cyber symposium are they no they
rebranded so what happened so the reason
that i brought this up earlier was the
same [ __ ] that he pushed last year
he just rebranded it because there was
so much of an embarrassment because what
happened was
not only did they have tons of technical
problems on like
sharing screens and pulling up documents
you had uh
what's his face who ran in the state of
arizona who got like seven percent uh
watkins yeah watkins he showed up
original queues or something
and like a live stream right yeah yeah
and then he was uh he basically called
them out to be like you guys don't have
you guys don't know what you're talking
about and every time that you talk about
how there's going to be some big kind of
reveal something goes wrong or you don't
have it or it's less than what you
thought it was so that happened in real
time on the show or this cyber symposium
so now
they're saying okay we're not going to
go cyber symposium anymore we're going
to call it the moment of truth summit
which again these people love to use the
word truth right they misuse the word
truth because they don't know what the
actual definition is they misuse the
word god and religion in actual being a
christian because they don't know what
it actually is and here you have an
example of those two things merging like
what's the truth like ben gleb talked
about it in his special where he talked
about like these things that were
written in the bible a little bit biased
because it was written by those people
that that are pushing it but also it's
like
there weren't really any witnesses it
was people telling a story about a story
about a story about a story and then
someone writing it down right
it's [ __ ] ridiculous the best part
about this clip
is these people have so much conceit
that i gave if you catch it
they're actually they're not asking for
god's blessing
they are blessing god this is how far
down this fascist rabbit hole that they
are and i want to explain why this is
funny but i want to explain why this
mindset is so [ __ ] dangerous watch
this the holy spirit we say come king of
glory
we want to thank you today we want to
praise you what i i'm not sure the the
lady in the paint she's praying right
but the one in the black is she going
stop stop stop wait wait i can't figure
out what she's doing yeah i don't know i
can't figure out what she's doing let's
let's keep watching we want to
acknowledge god that you are god and you
are worthy of of our uh our praises our
she's like can't hold my arms are that
long
did you hear did you hear this listen to
what she says of of our uh
worthy of of our
damn it here you are god and you are
worthy of of our our praises our god you
god are worthy of our praises
so god god must be flattered at this
point yeah he's like oh [ __ ] i'm worthy
very much well son of a [ __ ] look i
thought i thought i had this wrong the
whole time i thought you had to be
worthy but it turns out
the tables have turned
and i
am now worthy of you [ __ ] son of a
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] have out god
god listen it gets better listen to this
thanks
god and we you've been so good to us and
we praise you we thank you we bless you
we bless you we
he's like bless you
here here's a bunch of boneheads
standing up on stage at the moment of
a fraud summit and they're telling god
that they're gonna bless god are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me they're like god we
know you've been busy you know
making
well
there was something i wanted to say in
the last segment which was like the fact
that these people use god as their
example they're like oh man thank god we
were able to help this person right
thank god that whatever [ __ ] excuse
they want to come up with but it's like
whenever there's a good thing like oh
this person became pregnant thank god
turns out that she had a miscarriage and
the baby did not survive oh thank god
like wha why why are you thanking god
like you you thinking god that she's
alive like you're thanking god that she
what what happened here like you would
you'll thank god when it's a miracle but
you'll blame [ __ ] satan
when [ __ ] goes wrong it's like you don't
think that god was like uh
that's why god is [ __ ] right this
whole idea of like only good things are
from god
[ __ ] that [ __ ] especially when you
say
oh well this was what the this is what
the plan was you got to you got to trust
the plan this is this is how it was
meant to be it was really meant to be
don't you think god would have done
something to make everything good
well i agree
and and really
this this because i i'm an atheist yeah
i think you're an atheist but i i i
think i think you're yes i'm a [ __ ]
atheist okay you're an atheist i'm i'm
are you offended that i say i think you
are yeah you're like look we've had this
conversation you even imply imply how
can i dare you how dare you yeah
you are not even worthy okay i i bless
you i bless you i bless you
thank you here's here's the thing here's
the thing
is that even even as atheist right i
mean there's something to the morality
of christianity like the second half of
the book right yeah yeah yeah there's
something to that morality that you know
it rings it rings in a lot of uh
societies right um the idea of tolerance
the idea of you know equity and equality
and
acceptance right acceptance right um you
know all that stuff but here you have uh
two karen's on stage um and they're
going to anoint themselves so so much of
a high power here that they're going to
bless
the infallible god right yeah
because what you're saying is like
there's an infallible god but he seems
that infallibility seems to be
contradicted at every turn with these
people
but here you have these these
morons
and sweaters here gonna
have so much conceit in themselves and
they think they have so much spiritual
power that they're going to
um
they're going to bless god now this is
important historically because this is
exactly what nazi germany did right nazi
germany well their their founding of
fascism was founded on christianity
and the aim was the aim was that hitler
was so you know
he was a prophet he was a prophet sent
by god so much so that he became the
idea of god and so much so that they
almost didn't look to god as much as
they looked to hitler to praise god and
use their ideology
to anoint things and to tell god what
god believed that's where we're headed
here when this because i don't actually
think she's doing this like
consciously like she's not standing
there you know trying to flatter god
this is subconscious this has been
cooked into this person's lunatic brain
and has been cooked in here has been
deluded inside of her and that's why
she's saying because i i honestly i've
been to a lot of churches uh in my day
different churches right
i attended different style churches and
i have never that i can remember
had someone stand up
and act like they were going to bless
god like i've never i've never really
witnessed that before until this moment
i'm like i mean it's [ __ ] it's a it's a
bold move you know it's like that it's
like that scene it's like that scene
from dodgeball he's like bold move
cotton let's see how it plays out you
know like it's one of those moments
where you're like you have the audacity
to go and say
i bless this omnipotent being that is
god right this all-powerful can wield
whatever he [ __ ] wants
like you're saying that you
are blessing him and he
it should be so lucky to get such a
blessing right which is like a weird way
of being like god blessed you but now
you're blessing god because somehow you
became more powerful than god like what
the [ __ ] is going on here right
and that's this idea that these you know
white nationalist christians
believe that they
are messengers of god right they have
become so powerful
that control
and suppression and oppression of others
that they say
i am now as powerful as god because i
can tell you
what you can do with your body and where
you can go that's right and what you can
read and what you can say that's right
and who you can love and whatever it is
when you get that power people get a
little [ __ ] crazy man and they think
that they're god
and they think that they are un
unfucking you know they're they are
invincible
and it gets very dangerous and now it's
better than early signs of you better
not speak out against any kind of right
fascist prophet because if you do we we
we we played last week that alex jones
was now in support of desantis
and he was kind of rebuking trump
but
he kind of had to tuck tail and running
he got he got it he got up against a
rock and a hard spot between the the
orange mussolini jesus
and he had to kind of recant here let's
listen
so this is my emergency message to you
emergency message to mr president are
you [ __ ] serious
this can't be serious right he can't
believe this garbage right
this can't be a person i don't know man
[ __ ] like come on every every day i say
they can't be that dumb and then
something happens and i go okay maybe i
mean this is all theater right let's
watch again watch as he says this
so this is my emergency message to you
mr president to go and actually watch
the first 30 minutes of thursday's show
we'll put a link to it below here so you
can see what i said in context the
corporate media edited down a 30 second
clip to make it sound like that i'm only
for the santas this is hilarious
apparently where the corporate media now
with the corporate media because we took
a clip of his show and we played it on
our show and clearly he stated that he
was abandoning trump and he was going to
support desantis but i mean you know
watch the first 30 minutes gabe because
the corporate media is trying to twist
the context here of which he abandoned
trump i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about this is not the first time
that alex jones has done this
he'll go against trump i mean you know
back away back away yeah yeah he'll
he'll he'll push it and then be like oh
[ __ ] like i don't know what happened if
he heard whispers of of someone
saying uh trump was very upset with you
or if he saw the you know the the
pushback from his audience probably
right or the media machine churning out
this fabricated altered distorted
statement that he made and he's like oh
no no i can't just say anything and and
not
be uh invincible and not have
repercussions right but this is him
getting on his knees and groveling and
be like sir president trump please like
and the other thing too is if this
really was a message for trump i'm sure
he could find some way to get to roger
stone and get it to donald trump right
right he would have a private channel
i'm ready to call the dude he probably
called the dude
this
is a is an attempt to publicly state
he's like oh i'm the victim they
skewed and played and manipulated what i
always said
like representative collins he's the
victim right exactly
if it goes if it doesn't go your way
then you just like turn course and say
oh no no no no
despite the fact that it was unedited
and you guys heard everything i said
and i meant what i said when i said it
now people don't like what i said so now
i got to play the victim and say oh well
you know
they they did it to me
just like they did it to you mr
president like you're the victim i'm the
victim we're worse in pachiko man we are
amigos
we are connected at the hip by being
victims from mainstream media or from
the left or whatever it is so this is
him attempting to save face in front of
his audience
because yes like you said they probably
came out were like oh what the [ __ ] dude
that's not right don't hold on hold on
don't even though they're watching this
competition go on between ron desantis
and donald trump
in in some ways i feel like it's too
early
to put your uh your eggs in a certain
basket right to collect certain
deplorables and put it in a basket this
is one of those moments where it's too
early and i think
certain people are unsure of which side
to go for especially if this 2024 run
happens with either of them
and that's what's happening is he's like
oh whoa whoa whoa no no no trump is the
president
trump is our president he's going to run
in 2024. but until the announcement
happens or ron desantis decides to go as
a contender
people are saying that he's jumping the
gun and in my mind i think is there they
they're they're upset that he made an
assumption here that they have to go for
this guy versus that guy well but having
said that having said that
and you think about that for a second
right because um alex jones in this
universe of
you know i was talking about it in the a
block the first 30 minutes of the tail
wagging the dog because the tail always
wags it up no matter what you want to
believe the tail always wags the dog
that's how it works
but if you take it through that prism
here
maybe just maybe and we know that alex
jones is about performing a performative
art yeah i mean
don't put it past him that this was all
contrived from the very beginning right
and maybe it's just a way
to signal
through
his his audience
to rhonda santis and trump who is the
actual king here
you follow what i mean so what a guy
could do if he had an audience like alex
jones has an audience he knows how much
control
he has over his audience hearing what he
says he knows they hear it he knows they
respond so what if he was like you know
what how can we really prove
not to just
themselves but to ron desantis and trump
even who the king of the mogalodites are
right who's the king of the magadites
right well what alex jones could do is
he could contrive
a situation where he would turn on trump
and support desantis yep and see
how his audience will respond because he
knows he knows he's not going to lose
right he's not yeah he could yeah he
could test the waters and you know we
could say that's what he did and then he
learned that people are not ready right
to make that jump yet well and even this
even this statement that we watched here
this statement here could be contrite
that they he knew
that he would come out and give this
emergency message to trump yeah to also
show and solidify
of who is the king of manga who's the
manga king
i mean i'm not saying that that there's
some kind of conspiracy theory here but
when you have the conspiracy theory guy
doing these conspiracy things and trying
to contort his audience and trying to
pull his audience in a way with his
media
to see who is actually because this
would be a good way for alex jones even
to gauge his audience to see what they
thought about him supporting desantis
over trump
and going in that direction maybe his
audience maybe he was trying to figure
out maybe they will maybe they'll
support him instead of trump and i'll go
that direction right yeah you know what
i think um because i talked to kelly
jones alex jones's ex-wife
uh i talked to her on stuttering john's
podcast maybe i should um
maybe we should get her on and ask her
about this specifically i know she's
busy but maybe we should try to see if
we can ask her about this situation like
get inside the mind of alex jones is
this is this real or is this all
[ __ ] because i actually i actually
think this is all [ __ ] made up this
is all [ __ ] he's actually doing this
like he does everything else to his
audience like we watched in the trial i
believe nothing that alex jones says or
does
is for anything but to manipulate his
audience 100
like the entire entirety of his media he
he absolutely does not believe anything
he has no principles whatsoever his only
goal is to manipulate his audience and
to make sure that they think the way
that he wants them to and to try to
guide him through this path of [ __ ]
delusion let's finish what he says here
though because it it almost gets even
sweeter at the end said that i've
abandoned you that's not true
it's the contrary
i understand you're under attack i
understand you are surrounded and i'm
trying to get you to re-assess the
situation i know
people like don
are telling you that you need to
reassess a situation
reassess the situation so he alex jones
is doing is doing donald trump a favor
here the way right
he goes look guys i get it i get it you
are under attack and i'm under attack
not just because of this but because i
you know i lost this defamation lawsuit
on which i attacked these families of
these of these victims
and told all of you that it was a
[ __ ] hoax and then you attacked them
and now i got to pay the sins that you
guys and i committed here
but he's like he's like i get it i get
it you're victims i'm a victim we're all
victims even like doesn't even say he
doesn't take donald trump or the
president or whatever the former
president he says
done
done
is what it means because if you i like i
don't know he because he would call
trump president right right that's what
i need but i'm like i don't know if
you're like short like you're just like
bringing to me like me and don
like we're like we're amigos you know
kind of thing do you think maybe don jr
put him up to this because don jr can't
get his dad on the phone but he knows he
knows that the president will watch
we'll watch
i mean that's possible he could be like
dad dad look at this message look at
this message that alex jones sent you i
got him to say this could this all be
could this all be just just don jr
trying to get his dad's attention the
whole thing whatever
you just have to assume that anytime don
jr says something in public
there is
there is a deep rooted
desire to get attention right he's like
oh i got seal team friends you know i
got these friends these friends that
said this whole thing was crazy that
this is that this is not how we should
do things and then you know he's hoping
he's like oh maybe if i go to this thing
and i make this statement that my dad
will eventually see it because it'll be
covered on some news station
or like the unread text like i'm sure i
guarantee that he leaves his son on red
yeah like he says hey dad you know like
uh you want to maybe go get like
breakfast today oh it doesn't even go in
the thread is what you're saying
yeah well no i think he looks at it and
he leaves it on red like he has the read
receipts on there and he just leaves
them on red so then there's all these
messages that show like red at 8 42 a.m
reddit 9 46 a.m you think he shows the
receipt so don knows hey i'm ignoring
yeah yeah he goes i'm the real
i'm the real powerful one here i see i
will praise you with my graces
when you are ready i see well speaking
of people who like to say things in
public to get attention here's rudy
kaluti grandpa farty machete rudy
giuliani saying he's not doing so well
man the deep state is trying to kill
trump or some [ __ ] listen to this this
is [ __ ] nuts before in third world
countries and banana republics they
arrest the
former uh opponent they don't kill him
they kill him they arrest them
donald trump should be in any fear of
the deepest of deep stations maybe
killing him i do
[Music]
oh my god
it's literally literally this is rudy
giuliani saying the deep state is going
to kill donald trump i mean it doesn't
get any
why are these people watching so many
movies they're watching way too many
[ __ ] movies the way i can see this
well i mean how can you see it any other
way well there's no other way because
they want their life to be
this interesting they want it to be this
dramatic they want people to believe
that oh well
uh if there's something going wrong it's
not just because i [ __ ] up and i did
something wrong like it's not because of
my incompetent legal team is gonna [ __ ]
up this whole uh fbi searching my
property because i stole documents
illegal documents that i should not have
had right it's not this what ends up
happening is these people are like oh
well i have to fabricate this whole
story about how someone's trying to
assassinate me or like how there's a an
extortion plot against me by the fbi or
like whatever it might be right there
you are how sick you are and you can't
be you can't uh testify in a criminal
probe possibly where you're implicated
in crimes or you're trying to overthrow
uh fair elections in our democracy is
this really him in a wheelchair this is
him this is rudy giuliani it's a hardly
on the harvey weinstein thing where he's
getting
and well this is what happens i think
when i think at a certain point like i
think harvey weinstein i think like the
actual health like that [ __ ] really you
know i think for some like dramatic
effect but i think also it's [ __ ]
happening
no i know i know
oh i don't know i i want to say i want
to believe i want to believe that yes
some of it was theater but some other
parts of it
was just the overall stress of him being
like oh [ __ ] i am [ __ ] right now
coming at him right because before he
was like oh i'm the head of the previous
studio i actually think he's still the
he still thinks he's going to get away
with this harvey weinstein himself he's
going to win these appeals and [ __ ] i
think these people are so [ __ ] are so
so dis disconnected from what reality is
that they have no idea what
accountability or or what it even feels
like and rudy giuliani is one of them i
haven't watched this video i haven't
seen this video i didn't even know this
existed so i see him in the wheelchair
and i go maybe watch this what was this
uh a few days ago or yeah a couple yeah
a couple days ago but here's the thing
if you're in a wheelchair it's like yeah
well here's the thing you're either
because it doesn't look good one you're
either strong republican maga right
you're with trump or right now you look
weak it's one or the other you're either
you're and you can't be strong
if you're in a wheelchair by having some
person with airways whatever
push you around the airport because you
can't walk the 500 yards to the exit or
to your plane or whatever it might be
yeah well but it doesn't play well
when
when you have it because this is if if
he is making this up and this is theater
then he's been like i'm the victim i am
put under a lot of stress right now and
it is unfair and i did my job so it's
like if you did everything right and
you're innocent then you should have you
should not need to be pushed around you
should be able to walk from the gate to
the exit or the exit or the entrance to
the gate you have no problem this may
not have anything to do with rudy's
health this may have to do with the
bottle in his pocket is all i'm saying
but and the other thing too is that you
know these people know these dog
whistles they know this [ __ ] they
and they know how to buy into it they
know how to translate this nonsense just
like if you'll pull up the if you'll
give me the clip of uh ron desantis
talking about woke-ism and [ __ ] um in
that one which one i feel like there's
so many now there was one over the
weekend where he
his his tiny little head was on top of
his his trump body where he's trying to
do the best impersonation of trump that
he can
but he's talking about wokism but they
believe this nonsense this they they
know the dog whistles they know how
they're supposed to translate this but
watch let's watch this clip of rudy and
i'm being hauled to the airport because
he's too drunk to walk
the district attorney said at the end mr
giuliani satisfied his obligation under
the subpoena so i was very happy that i
satisfied my application oh he's very
happy that he sanders found his
obligation even though he refused to try
to satisfy that obligation until the
court made him do it like they literally
had to force him to do this because he
he was trying to say that he he had a
medical procedure and then he was i
don't know what the [ __ ] else he was
saying he's saying all kinds of lies
yeah all kinds of [ __ ] lies here is
um
this is at some other turning points
nazi thing yep another one every weekend
man they're [ __ ] printing money over
there oh my god what the hell why can't
we have our own circus i've been asking
this question
people ask me all the time whenever i do
a clip on something like this and
they're like why don't do we have one
like some people are like legitimately
like do we have one of these and i'm
like no we we just do right we do not do
this i don't know why we don't do the
the circus we should do the circus all
the time
it's definitely yeah it would be one a a
great way to fundraise for local
elections right uh and also to help
the messaging
but in this context it's like
you we don't have that opportunity
because we believe oh you know we we
shouldn't we shouldn't go down to their
level they'll [ __ ] that we should meet
them where they are that's right do a
better job of it damn right i mean i we
should have these things and we should
do a better job of messing we should
talk about all the different acts that
biden has passed we should talk about
who in the party is is an up-and-coming
candidate and who is doing good things
for their local area that they're you
know nearby whatever it might be
but i think we should even have like a
phone company called the woke mobile and
it should have outside the booth at our
circus at woke mobile it should have a a
cardboard cutout of rambo with joe but
dark brandon's head on it oh yeah that's
what i think and then we should we and
he instead of holding a gun he should be
holding a big banner of all the [ __ ]
that dark brandon actually got i mean
also an ice cream cone wow can't forget
the ice cream cone that's true that's
true i mean an ice cream and ice cream
is some vicious i mean when you're
really trying to i've never seen donald
trump wear sunglasses
so i've only seen i've only seen joe
biden wear aviators so i feel like if
we're going to go into that like style
of genre it makes sense to put that face
on there right but still it's i mean
it's [ __ ] cringy as [ __ ] but let's
just yeah i guess we'll just lean into
it i i bet i bet the reason why the
cheeto deaths mobster um grandpa
poopypants um trump can't put glasses on
is because it would it would smear his
makeup all right you know right well
also i think also if you put them on and
you take them off it would [ __ ] up with
the hair right it could get caught and
then you'd have these like wings out to
the side probably that's probably what
it is it's probably that's why he drinks
out of straws did you know everyone
thinks it's some kind of cognitive thing
he drinks he drinks out of straws
because he doesn't want to [ __ ] up his
makeup
that's a and and i have a mustache so
when i drink like you know if i drink a
big glass of water i'm gonna have water
all over my yeah over my mustache just
like donald trump he takes the little
little sips if he doesn't have a straw
because he didn't he didn't want to get
on his face because his makeup would run
like rudy giuliani's [ __ ] for brains was
running out of him when he was sweating
his ass off trying to come up with lies
but speaking of lines let's listen to
this fascist the fascist of florida
um
talk about
wokism as if it's gonna kill us or some
[ __ ] i don't know i think in florida and
we need this to be true in pennsylvania
around the country
we can't just stand idly by why why
while woke id
wow wow
blah blah blah
wow
you know it's really funny when they go
on tirades and they they bash other
politicians
um who have a stutter who can't
sometimes get that word out and they
make fun of them when this guy who who
he may or may not i don't know but he he
can't he can't seem to walk on while
woke right let's listen again and but
nope we i'm sure i'll be bashed for
making fun of him let's listen can't
just stand idly by why what why while
woke ideology ravages every institution
in our society what the hell does that
mean what in the [ __ ] does that mean
ravage our society the hell does that
even mean well here's what it means gabe
do you want me to tell you what it means
yeah sure i can tell you what it means
white people around the country hear
exactly what that means
it means whatever the [ __ ] they want it
to mean baby if they don't like if they
don't like black people if they don't
like the lgbt community they don't like
gay people if they don't if they don't
like liberals if they don't like
democrats if they don't like jews
whoever that is
that is the call here
that is the call that he's tr that is
the dog whistle he is sending out he is
saying woke
because that word can mean whatever the
[ __ ]
the violent ones want it to mean
you know this you know this they say
they they do this [ __ ] in comments all
the time even with you they'll say stuff
to gabe like go back to your country
yeah right or i hope ice deports you
which i'm like i'm assassinating how are
they going to take you they're gonna
take you back to chicago i guess so i
guess so i don't know well yeah it looks
like you grew up in yep okay great but
again this is the dog whistle that he is
trying to portray here and remember
where he's doing it he's doing it in
pennsylvania as he's trying to support
the the nazi candidate for governor in
pennsylvania where he's trying to throw
a dog whistle around like the word woke
and again i don't even know what the
hell it means but he continues here well
they just throw woke on whatever if
there's ever a problem that you know or
they ever see an issue with something
and they need
to platform on it they'll just be like
oh that's woke it's like but is it is it
woke no it's not it's just well several
years ago it was own the libs right now
it's now it's this woke thing they come
up with a new word to really to really
blanket anyone if you are if you are a
person who cares about other people
right whether it's like hey i wore a
mask to protect myself from and myself
and also you from getting sick or like
uh i care about people having you know
housing or health care or you know or
just dropping what
right exactly that [ __ ] is radical and
it's woke tony it is radical woke
[ __ ] it's like if you're trying to be
a normal human [ __ ] you know following
christian principles pretty much
uh you're woke dude you're [ __ ] woke
well it's not it's not um
it's not surprising that a turning
points action event here that he's
giving what seemed to be
1930-1940 style anti-semitic
dog whistles like nazi germany but let's
continue you cannot look away you have
to see what these people are doing it is
super important
we must fight the woke in our schools we
must fight the woke in our businesses we
must fight the woke in government
agencies we can never ever surrender to
woke ideology
and i'll tell you this
the state of florida is where woke goes
to die
no one no one
no one is waking up and lord they're all
asleep down there they are just fast
asleep
i don't understand what the hell and
then these people cheering for this
stuff
which is really that is the thing that
should terrify people
is that there is a tail out there
willing to wag the dog of this fascism
because that's really what he's talking
about the dog whistle that he's giving
here is anyone out there
who is not you
who is not a white christian who is not
a nationalist who is not an america
first nazi who is not someone who hates
the lgbtq community so much so that
they'll believe stuff like monkey pox
is a scourge of gay people or some
crazy-ass [ __ ] there are people calling
for the parents of children who have
monkey pox to be to be jailed yeah
because their children got monkey pox
because apparently there's there's a lot
of children receiving monkey pox because
it's a rash it's a goddamn rash and
children spread around ranches because
they share toys and [ __ ]
why can't why don't these people
understand that wokeness
is not what you think it is and i would
like to ask ronda santos that quote well
i'd like to ask him a couple questions
yeah yeah the first question is because
you know they're always running around
like what's a woman what the woman gave
do you know what a woman is i would like
to ask ron desantis what what's a woker
what is a woker can you describe a woker
for me i think john kennedy uh yeah he's
the one who's like these wokers you know
i'd love for him to tell us in a
non-southern fake accent what woker
means you know
mother wokers let's let's let's move on
because i've had enough of the the
fascists from florida uh king king ron
here
um so let's let's move on from him what
else do we have trending today um did
you hear this story about dennis rodman
surely i heard that he's going to go to
russia to fix this issue with
i mean i think this story is laughable
it has a funny computer if he wants to
go
over there like if he wants to stupid if
he wants to go
by all means go
right like if you think you can solve
this problem
then go for it uh
you know
it seems like a problem for professional
people you know the
legislators and people that are involved
in it actually but if dennis rodman
wants to go for it i mean [ __ ] he was
kim jong-un's uh favorite friend so do
you think he knows where this is coming
from is like he he he did not do a good
job of negotiating
kim jong-un he just went there and
because kim jong-un thought he was cool
because he was a basketball player or
some [ __ ]
i don't i don't understand or maybe i
don't know maybe he's like i'll go there
and you know you got you dictators you
guys know each other you guys hang out
maybe we can get a little powwow and we
can talk about how to get this person
out right so he's like maybe that's
dennis rodney is the middleman where
it's like this world of dictator and
basketball and in the middle
it's it's britney and dennis right and
they're you know he can only save her
right because he has a connection to kim
jong-un and kim jong-un known as putin
and putin is holding brittany and so
then he thinks maybe he can influence
that situation and then somebody's like
a friend friend of my friend i'll get a
hold of him and he'll fix it right yeah
yeah cause you know here's the thing is
they're both basketball players right
dennis rodman and brady grinder or bull
basketball they're both americans
um brittany griner seems to be wanting
to come home
and dennis rodman really wants to go to
russia and we normally in this country
we're very used to this
this trading of basketball players for
team to team i'm just saying is this an
option where we could tr because they
want to have the the russia wants this
this uh military what is this is this a
person a spy that they want to trade
there's someone they want to trade
they're a spy or something but i'm
saying really honestly if we're going to
trade a basketball player for a
basketball player and we're gonna you
know take sides and you know do the
trading of teams here i am willing
i am willing to go out on a limb here
and say most americans would be okay
with the trade option
right of brittany griner for dennis
rodman as opposed to this uh this spy
that they want yeah
victor bout
and like anyone i i saw someone in here
uh the
the people that call themselves or that
the group calls fake gabe in here in the
chat he says
rodman's doing more than biden but
i think we should also call out the fact
that the biden administration has
already offered the convicted russian
arms dealer in exchange for grindr so
don't come in here and say he's doing
more than biden
the guy's doing that on top of the fact
that he's also passing
sweeping legislation
with no support from republicans
to help u.s citizens so he's doing one
thing and also discussing this other
[ __ ] because he's able to multitask
well i want to point out something too
here to
to fake gabe or whatever the point is
it's really the underlying story here
of brittany griner being detained and
being sentenced to nine years in russia
people like gabe in the chat and people
that you know who talk about well she
deserves it she did what she got what
she got and all this [ __ ]
you are weaponizing
russia
you are doing their bidding their war
their war against us as americans you're
their weapon
your their ammunition because what
you're doing what you're doing by saying
that brittany griner should stay over
there and russia she get what she
deserve blah blah blah
because gabe
frankly they hate her number one she's a
successful woman she's black and she's a
lesbian they hate that they absolutely
[ __ ] hate that about her and i'm not
talking i'm not talking about russia i'm
talking about the people who russia
weaponized in this country to be so
un-american
so un-american that they would tolerate
someone
who had residue
residue
from a drug that was legal here
and she get sentenced to nine years in a
russian prison unless we trade an arms
dealer
you're upset you're upset that we're
trading in arms dealing is your fault
yeah it's you you are giving russia
power here they are the ones who
detained
they detained and sentenced brittany
greiner into prison because they knew
that you dumb [ __ ] who are out
there pushing for putin and putin's
puppet and [ __ ] with fascism and
trumpism and manga
you pieces of [ __ ] out there who have
those [ __ ] easy diluted minds
so much so that putin can [ __ ]
convince you
that that
we
we should go to war
because we shouldn't give up an arms
dealer putin knew he was gonna get the
arms deal are you dumb [ __ ] and
the reason why he knew he was gonna get
the arms dealer is because of people
like you pushing propaganda like you're
pushing and believing the fascist ideas
that you believe because you're playing
in the putin's narrative you're playing
into his delusion you're playing into
his hands
that is what you're doing you are
spreading the warfare of russia on truth
because that's really the war we're
fighting here it's not a war on
information it's a war on the truth is
what they're trying to do and by you
saying oh dennis reitman dennis rodman's
doing more for this country than joe
biden never met get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] you are believing more of
the [ __ ] russian propaganda you are
the russian machine you are a good
russian soldier fake gabe you are a
great russian soldier and i'm glad i'm
glad you've picked a side and you pick
the [ __ ] team you want american
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] because in this in
this chat and on this show we are about
americans we are about democracy and we
are about the truth and you sir need to
pluck your head
out of your ass and realize that
brittany griner is an american and putin
used you and your deluded little mind to
convince the entire world that he could
detain her he could jail her so that way
he could get his arms dealer back so if
you're mad if you're mad that they're
gonna get an arms dealer and trade for
brittany griner that is your fault you
did that you put this on the world you
did that so maybe maybe tomorrow when
you wake up
and you go down to get your cup of
coffee before you put your your maka
tears in it
maybe maybe what you should do is think
about the actions that you take in this
country when you're a traitor and you're
turning
putin's weapons of war on us and it's
called [ __ ] disinformation and
[ __ ] russian propaganda you're doing
putin's bidding you're part of the
problem and that's why brittany griner
is in the situation that she is in and
that's why our government is thinking
about trading arms dealer for brittany
griner because of people like you and
the situation that we're in because you
people just can't stop believing
whatever the [ __ ] you want to believe
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] just forget about
the truth
we love the lies keep feeding them to us
putin we'll do your bidding we'll be
your weapon of war here in america we'll
be your war on truth we're a good
russian soldier so put on your uniform
fake game and be that russian soldier
that you're born to be
because you're not an american all right
well i think that's about that's about
all i got from that yeah yeah no the
only thing i was gonna add was you know
good job comrade very good drill but the
other thing that i was gonna say was the
fact that
when you know let's say this trade does
happen and they go okay we're gonna
we're gonna trade in this uh arms dealer
this russian arms dealer that we've had
for brittany griner as soon as that
trade happens if it happens
the the right will say how dare you
how dare you trade and put an arms
dealer back on the market like that's as
soon as it'll flip when when when the
when the consideration is happening
right now to say hey we want to bring
this person back want to bring britney
back to america and trade it for an arms
dealer a russian arms dealer they will
support that 100 percent and then as
soon as that trade happens they'll go
well well what the [ __ ] you do you just
put america
in danger by allowing this arms dealer
to go back to russia
so you can't have it anyway you you
can't win no
it's it's always a lose-lose when
republicans like fake gabe in the chat
are trying to make a point that is very
distorted and very much under a
propagandist way of thinking
well i mean when all you're doing is
listening to [ __ ]
just absolute misinformation russian
propaganda from places like fox news
talk radio
charlie kirk tucker carlson uh people
like marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
steve bannon donald trump himself who's
a russian agent and was a russian agent
contends to continues to be an agent for
russia and saudi arabia then you do get
a little deluded and you lose track of
who the actual american is and why why
it seems like america's in such a sticky
situation with putin i think it's
because that putin has support in this
country and it's you it's you
propagating their weapon of war of
misinformation and we will stand none of
that here on the tony michaels podcast
because we support pro-democracy and we
support our democracy and we think you
should engage so support pro-democracy
speech everywhere if you support our
show you can go to
support.tonymichaelspot.com
show your support there give us a like
give us a share subscribe to the youtube
channel don't forget to do that also you
can support us by going over and
following us on twitter you're not going
to want to miss the poll for bonehead of
the week this week we already got a
bunch of boneheads racked up and don't
forget i mean i've already got an idea
of who the alpha cuck is but i mean it's
already monday it's monday we're already
on monday and i've already got an idea
who alpha [ __ ] is but by thursday
they
well really by friday morning when i
make the final pick on who that is i
mean that could very well change it
probably will change i mean we've got
matt gates has his primary tomorrow oh
my god so we can i don't know something
like that own heads boneheads everywhere
so download every single episode of the
tony michael's podcast speaking of uh
bonehead gabe we're gonna have some
breaking news with bonehead later on in
the week
um i'm gonna keep floating that there's
some news there's some great news about
bone end of the week
so stay tuned every single episode this
week monday through friday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific on youtube
twitter and twitch also simulcasting
from the midas touch facebook page don't
forget to tune in on every single one of
them you're not gonna wanna forget
because there's gonna be big news coming
about bonehead of the week so stay tuned
stay in your seat engage in your
democracy
and surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking